hey there everyone I'm IAD and I'm in my
junior year of high school welcome to my
very first episode of this podcast
series and what I want to share and shet
with you guys today is a very I can say
it's a very likable topic nowadays an
Ultimate Guide to make money online let
us not waste time and dig into
it so we're discussing about money in
this episode because firstly more people
should do it and secondly because money
can be a huge stress in most of our
Lives often we feel like we don't have
enough of it and many of us work more
than 80,000 hours of our life trying to
earn a livelihood which is a huge chunk
of our time in this
earth however the ability to make money
online apart from our day jobs is quite
appealing it means that if you love our
job and happy days we can have some
Spirit cash for a vacation on the other
hand if we are not entirely content with
working 40 to 80 hours a week we have
the option to go part-time if not that
we can take a lower paying job if not
that either then we can stop working all
together if we desire of course this is
not an overnighted achievement it takes
time effort and some luck to reach the
point where we can quit our our jobs and
be financially stable honestly everyone
after listening to this podcast I don't
think they will not be curious about
making an extra few hundred EUR each
month the process of getting there is
not as mysterious as it might seem let's
break it down essentially there are only
three legitimate ways of making money
online but before we explore those we
need to understand the fundamentals we
need to discuss what money is there's a
poem from the early 19s that sums it
up which is as follow money is a matter
of functions as a medium as a measure a
standard a store at its core money is
just a medium for exchanging value we
all use money to purchase thing that we
find valuable therefore if we want to
make money or make money online we need
to provide some kind of value that
someone else is willing to pay for since
I started my freshman year in high
school uh I've been captivated by other
people's success not only because they
made themsel financially independent but
they also retired their parents at a
young age which was very inspiring so I
started seeing out information materials
and sources so I can do the same thing
and today I'm going to give you the
first piece of the
puzzle there are essentially three forms
of value that people will pay for over
the
internet and this translate into three
levels of making money online which is
level one Services level two products
and level three attention level one is
about selling your services this one's
probably the easiest way of making money
online is the one I recommended to
everyone to begin with there are only
two things we need to do firstly we need
to develop a skill that people are
willing to pay for and secondly we need
to find people who are willing to pay
for that skill if you're thinking that I
don't have any valuable skill that's
okay you got the internet and you can
learn a tons of uh things that you might
be interested
there are literally hundreds of services
you can offer online if you just look on
the website F or upwork and BR their
categories there are literally hundreds
if not thousands of different thing that
people will pay you to do having a Mon
Mon skill is not an excuse anymore at
all because if you want to actually make
money online because you can literally
teach anything over the internet and
then you can skill to
others the second step to make money
online is to find people who will pay
you money for the skill or service now
there are two sort of people who will
pay you for your services essentially
there are people in your real life or
secondly people on the internet a much
more long-term solution I would suggest
is that you can find people to pay for
your services over the internet now I've
learned this website coder.com from
YouTuber named Ali abdal A Doctor also
entrepreneur on which she
says I've got my start on a website
called get a coder.com where you know
people would post projects saying they
need a web designer or developer to do
various things and I would bid on those
projects and say ah I'll do it for $10
I'll do it for $5 I would basically
undercut everyone's else in the market
because I was like 12 13 and for me 5 or
dollars were were like oh my God I'm
rich these days this place is like up
work and fever that seems to be the
biggest one so you can just kind of bro
through all the different things people
are looking for and then you can sell
all
the services there you can say I'll do
it for a fiber I'll do it for 10 I'll do
it for
250 and over time as you get better at
the things you can start charging more
and more especially as you start getting
decent reviews and you start building up
your own portfolio the disadvantage of
this in a long run is that you are
trading time for money and that's
ultimately not very scalable model
because obviously time is limited and so
if you really want to make money online
then you want to get to the other step
the last step is about selling products
now there's a various various different
ways of doing this but just to simplify
for clarity the two that we're going to
talk about they are first Drop Shipping
and secondly affiliate marketing let's
start with drop Drop Shipping the basic
idea is that we could make a pretty
looking website that sells nice looking
watch let's say for €100 per piece when
a customer order the that watch we then
buy it from a third party that's
actually selling the watch and we
arrange them to ship it to the custumer
so we're making 50 without ever handling
the watch at all
now I've never really done this myself
and I would recommend you probably stay
away from it is as well just because
I've seen so many kind of online courses
that uh seem a little bit scamming the
second way of selling other people
product is affiliate marketing affiliate
marketing is when you're selling someone
else's stuff but you're getting a
commission from each sale like there's a
really good review uh website called
wire cutter and do reviews about the
best electron
and they do the reviews about the best
electronics in different categories and
they have an Amazon affiliate links so
when someone clicks on that link and buy
from Amazon then wi cutter the website
will make I don't know 1% 2% 3%
commission and on that seal and so if
you get enough visitors buying enough
things you can make a lot of money from
affiliate marketing or you can do what I
do which is to have affiliate
partnership with certain products like
there's the paper like screen protector
so if someone buys that paper like
screen protector for the iPad Pro using
my link I will get some per percentage
Commission on that sale and if enough
doing that that can make a reasonable
amount of money so that is how affiliate
marketing Works you're selling someone
else's stuff but you're getting a
percentage Commission on the sale if
you're interested in learning more about
this there's a dude uh called Pat Flynn
who runs the website and a podcast
called smart passive income and they've
got a lot of materials that teach you
the in ins and outs of how to do
affiliate marketing
properly so yeah those are the three
levels of making money online I thank
you all so much for listening to podcast
to this podcast hopefully we meet on the
next episode of this series te
entrepreneurship stay positive see you
soon